it's time for roses and rose say hello
I'm wearing a turtleneck it's relevant
you'll see why oh my goodness everybody
we had an episode of The Bachelor this
week that was only one hour long oh my
god I kind of liked it you know it's a
big time commitment every week and I
love the show but this self easy breezy
and beautiful like Nick mile what is she
doing here not so it was only an
hour-long episode but a lot happened
let's get to it
we start off this episode where we
finish last episode which was with the
Nick vile Andi Dorfman
bachelor/bachelorette ex drama all
unfolding at his hotel in New York City
why was he in New York City to see Andi
Dorfman
did he seem surprised yes he did hey V
magic
so andis like I heard you were in town
and next like this is born and I'm super
weird say they both need drinks for the
conversation the question is is it a
whiskey convo
or a wine kind of a thing Thanks is
conversation my conference whiskey
that's bad
so from here and he gives next some kind
of like vague advice on sex even a sex
appeal feminism and she says she's
ranting but says really seem like she's
ranting at home she tells him to sleep
with the women which is sort of weird
just like them sleeping together and
then talking about it on TV is like how
they ended up not getting along in the
first place yeah my advice I would look
no actually you've been there and done
it but then we got down to an apology
two years in the making without a voice
I'm sorry I'm never gonna find by Andy
okay back to the women they are in what
looks like the windiest rose ceremony
ever
and we're finally getting a rose
ceremony I don't remember the last time
we had one on this season the roses were
real but the trees looked fake they were
like very fall like trees and what
appeared to be winter
so Vanessa is crying don't feel special
and Corinne is sick sick to my stomach
honestly and Nic vile then cruising
packing vital for the fantasy suite this
whole time Corinne has been telling me
she would have sex with him I live in
Jeannie it's hot I mean this was a
surprising here's the thing people
thought Corinne was like a Chad Johnson
like a villain
so Corinne has done such a 180 this
woman I must drink to her limo speech
exit it was an actual moment of feminism
see jeans and mom think are appropriate
and now it I'm John Fisher I drink the
whole time she says office stuff okay
trying to show my men how much I'm
bortion them but I will never kiss up to
a man ever again in my life that ice is
so cold the ice like the turtleneck is
relevant I'm also wearing ugh you're
going to see why in a minute
so Corinne leaves with a slash and a
smash and asleep I want to go yes she
fell asleep in the limo
because Corinne is herself always
Corinne is gone I'm sure we'll see her
on paradise as the Bachelorette on her
own reality show hosting a dating game
show running our own corporation running
for president whatever is fine I'll take
it I love Corinne team corn now
everything I'm wearing and doing it
becomes relevant because Nick is going
to Finland what do we know about Finland
it's cold
that's all I know about Finland I came
in costume so Nick packs the world's
tiniest man bag to go to Finland and
somehow has a bunch of sweaters in there
which we see him wearing throughout the
episode including this turtleneck I have
never seen a turtleneck so high up on a
man's neck as unbelievable do we love it
do we hate it let me know also in
Finland vanessa is looking more
beautiful than ever really the snow blow
is working for her and Raven has a hack
and a Rachel has a hat
everyone is cool so since this episode
was only an hour we only saw Ravens one
on one turning into a fantasy suite kind
of a date so that's all we got but NIC
gives us a little more insight into his
relationship with Raven he says she's
crazy in a great fun way which I have
not really noticed about her and then he
says she's like a chocolate-covered
pretzel salty and sweet and then Raven
does some awesome math being physical
and emotional means double the
heartbreak so we're back to Raven and
Nick's date and he's wearing his
turtleneck and they're drinking wine I
really must have my eyelash extensions
for that and Raven then makes this
reveal that I must admit I in no way
shape or form saw coming I've never had
an orgasm before but kudos to Nick for
the way he responded him and his
turtleneck were not alarmed and even
bigger kudos and a big old drink to
Raven there you go
more people should be talking about the
female orgasm we need to lift the veil
and get it all out in the open
do you see how relevant or rather how
vaguely relevant me where so then Nick
and Raven retire to their tiny elephant
quarters in Finland I don't know what
the source is we are all left to wonder
on whether the date was satisfying will
Ravens date come to a satisfying end
there you go we'll see next week in a
three-hour bachelor special do we all
have the stamina glad desde oh so many
so many puns of so much fun hopefully
for raping girl get yours seriously
though I really enjoyed this episode a
lot of key awesome drama and fun
settings just good things and women
talking about women and I like when
reality TV has real moments like what
Raiden gave us oh yeah she owns it she's
honest and she's great and Nick looks
good in that turtleneck and look good
chopping this wood so we'll see what
happens with the wood and Nick and Raven
next week guys thanks so much for
watching make sure to LIKE EP on
Facebook subscribe to us on YouTube and
you can follow me on social media to
talk more about the bachelor things are
winding down we only have Raven Rachel
and Vanessa left who do you think next
going to pick I'm saying Vanessa but
just saying I'm just saying
everybody have a great night and
hopefully an orgasm Fame recording oh
okay oh my gosh is it all disgusting
we're all sweating when we're recording
right Wow sure that's bullsh oh okay